[Music]
bye
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
nazis are always just going to nazi
that's just the thing that's going to
happen
[Music]
is she or isn't she
you know what my opinion is she is 100
hondo
i mean jesus christ she's
self-proclaiming herself as a white
christian nationalist
so yeah absolutely she's a nazi and
to have her try to walk away from the
language
is a little ridiculous at this point why
don't they just embrace it why don't
they just like yeah we're yeah
absolutely why not
why not we have the we have the
republican
governor candidate candidate for
governor
being supported by the gab ceo
who basically says we don't want any
jews we don't want any jews we're not
supposed to have jews in our government
it's what he said
listen if they don't want to be called
nazis then maybe they just shouldn't i
don't know not be nazis
we've been talking about this since the
weekend
when there were nazis desantis
supporters who has he has not
yet
decried
outside the charlie kirk turning points
usa student conference
where the likes of matt goetz
also
basically self-proclaiming himself as a
christian nationalist
the new nazi they always rebrand they
always do this stuff we talked about
this yesterday with dakota adams and we
talked about it with dakota adams
several times these militia groups these
white nationalists they always rebrand
and rebrand and rebrand and rebrand
that's why we have patriot front now
you know what i'm talking about the the
the little incels that come out from
their mommy's basements and wear the
khakis and have the plastic shields and
they wear the face covering so you so
you can't identify them
after charlottesville when everyone
identified them and they all lost their
[ __ ] jobs because they're nazis
they started covering their face changed
the name and now they carry nice little
plastic shields instead of tiki torches
and this christian nationalism this
white creek
this white christian nationalism that
they're trying to rebrand themselves yes
yes
they're fascist that manga is fascist
trumpism is fascist
they're nazis
so much so that they're carrying flags
outside a turning point usa event
in support of the people inside not
protesting the people inside
so yes they are nazis
jesus christ we watched yesterday a clip
of donald trump acting like he was going
to set up little tent cities for
homeless people and it is it is rhetoric
that is going to be used as a sticking
point for concentration camps for anyone
they don't like
that's how it starts
that is how it starts folks
fascism is at the front door
it's there it's right there we can see
it plain as day we have to call it out
and when marjorie taylor green goes on a
far right show
and has to take the question are you a
nazi or not
we have them on their heels folks
we have them on their heels because
everyone's worried about the department
of justice and rather they're going to
prosecute trump and his allies
and all the seditious caucus as it were
that tried to overthrow our vote and
take away our democracy
on january 6
and even before that they were trying
and they're still trying today the soft
coup the soft slow-moving coup
to topless into a fascist state
ron desantis is the model in florida
they're at the front door
and they're ready to take over but we
have them on their heels
and as we discuss the department of
justice and rather they're going to
indict trump and his allies john eastman
jeffrey clark steve bannon mark meadows
and the like
we can indict them
we can convict them
we are the jury
the court of public opinion is way more
powerful than the department of justice
whoever dream of being
we have the ability this year the
midterm 2022
to indict
convict
and cast away the fascist in this
country including donald trump and
anyone who's supported by donald trump
you have that ability you have that
ability
and you better use it before you lose it
because they're coming for your vote
they most certainly are
i mean jesus you had 20 republicans who
voted in support of human trafficking
including rapey mcforhead
rapey mcforhead is trending this morning
and when you see rapey mcforhead
trending
you know exactly who it is
like you know you have to get you know
exactly who that is and he was one of
the ones matt goetz
was one of the ones
who voted for human trafficking not just
this isn't the first time he's voted for
it by the way in favor of human
trafficking and
what what better of a situation for matt
getz than someone who is an actual sex
trafficker an accused sex trafficker who
is under investigation for sex
trafficking minors would vote against
sextra humans sex trafficking of course
of course he would vote against it why
would he vote for it he wouldn't vote to
punish himself even more
and yet here we are he said he's a
member of congress
lauren bobert marjorie taylor greene
paul gosar
they all they all love to be called
christian nationalists
nazis jesus christ they pal around with
nick fuentes who is a holocaust denier
his his
banner is america first that's where
they got the language was nick fuentes
and nick fuentes op
adopted the the name america first
from from the american nazis
in the 1930s and the 1940s in this
country
where do you think that comes from
nazis
that's right
actual nazis
that was their tenement was america
first in this country
charles lindbergh and the like trying to
hide trying to hide their fascism
under american christian values well we
do not have to be tricked
time and time again
they want to rebrand
well guess what we can brand them the
way we want to brand them
that's right we can do this it's it's
obvious now that as long as we take our
gloves off and we get in the fight
of messaging
and pound the microphone day after day
after day after day after day after day
hour after hour after hour
just like they do with their lies we can
do it with the truth
and this year in 2022
we can indict and convict
trump his allies and anyone who supports
trump
and cast them out of politics for good
for good
but it's up to you if you want to engage
in your democracy if you want to do the
thing that is called democracy or not i
believe my audience is pro-democracy and
i believe you do want to participate and
engage in the ballot
have that strategic outrage stay pissed
continue continue the messaging every
single day do not let up and i'm not
just talking about marking your ballot
for who you want to vote for
i'm talking about actually engaging in
that ballot and engaging in democracy
talking to your friends your family
anything that you're good at if you're
good at text messaging if you're good at
calling if you got a little extra money
these democrats these pro-democracy
candidates because that's the only ones
out there
jesus you have a bunch of republicans
trying to court andrew yang into opening
up a new political party because they're
terrified they're terrified that
moderates and independents and
anti-trump republicans are going to vote
for the pro-democracy candidate which
are democrats
republicans are not pro-democracy
the nazis have taken over their party
and they're calling it christian
nationalism but it but it's fascism is
what it is
trumpism is fascism in a maga hat
don't be confused
and you have to brand it that way you
have to push it that way
when you're out there talking
there were nazis
actual nazis with nazi flags swastikas
the ss flag
giving the hal hitler sign
that showed up at a turning point usa
student conference
where on the inside you have a bunch of
politicians who are self-proclaimed
christian nationalists standing on stage
saying fascist [ __ ]
as if they're at a nazi rally
so yes when you're talking to your
community members your family your
friends
and they don't know much about politics
and they don't know much about the
discourse that is happening right now in
this country just get your phone out and
show them the video
of the nazis down in florida that were
in support of all those republicans
showing up at that nazi rally
and charlie kirk
it's the best part this is the best part
if they really weren't nazis if they
really weren't they wouldn't be offended
by this stuff they wouldn't be offended
they wouldn't get butt hurt by being
called nazis
they wouldn't
they'd be like ah yeah whatever ah
that's a bunch of [ __ ]
but charlie kirk's gonna sue it's gonna
sue the view because you caught me and
nancy
how dare you
marjorie taylor green is highly offended
and it hurts her and her family and
she's called it well stop being a nazi
then
i don't know what to tell you
it really offends me and my family my
friends and my constituents when you
call me i'm gonna show you a video
i'm gonna show you a video today
a marjorie taylor green claiming she's
not a nazi
i also have a special guest that's going
to join us today to talk about this
christian nationalism but also i want i
want to get her take on the doj
announcing
that that merrick garland and the doj
are are
going to investigate trump for the
january 6 and they they currently are
doing so
now the news broke this week we've
watched merrick garland several times
say yes
yes we will prosecute anyone who
committed crimes
it doesn't matter how high who cares it
doesn't matter even the former president
united states
can be indicted in the case of january 6
if he committed crimes
so i want to ask jessica denson
jessica joined us in the panel oh my i
think every panel actually now i think
about it all eight panels jessica joined
us
i believe so
maybe i'm i don't know
there was a lot
a lot of hearings there were a lot of
hours but i think jessica joined us
every single time
so she's going to join us today because
we haven't had a chance to talk about
the doj announcing that they're actually
that they actually have trump under
investigation for january 6.
so i want to get her take on that
because jessica jessica is the only
person
in the 2016 trump campaign that was able
to break the trump nda in court she beat
him in court so she knows how to beat
trump in court
maybe she can give us some insight on
how to beat him in the court of public
opinion
also as we watch
steve bannon's trial happen and he's
convicted
found guilty and he's going to be
sentenced soon then the coming months
i want to get her take on uh his
contempt charge
jessica has some history with steve
bannon so i want to uh ask her a few
questions about
scabby steve
that walking scab so i want to ask her a
few things about that
but me and jessica have had
conversations before
about christian nationalism and i i
think we should call it white christian
nationalism
i think that's what we should call it we
should not stop letting them brand
themselves as just christian
nationalists they're white christian
nationalists
hell give them the full brand that's
what they want why not let's do that
nazis going to nazi anyway so give it to
him let him have it white christian
nationalist
but we're going to talk about this
christian nationalism and how
unchristian it actually is today
on the tony michaels podcast coming up
at the bottom of the hour i'll bring
jessica in
now for our discussion on all these
topics gabe sanchez is not joining us
today again he is in a situation the
bunker that he is in i don't know if
gabe's listening but if if
the bunker that he is in is not allowing
him
uh the amount of wi-fi that he needs to
stream out
so he is he is still in the background
you can you notice the thumbnail still
is today is
is gabe's art
so he is still working hard in the
background but he's not able to join us
so jessica if if you can hear me in the
back in the green room it sounds like
you're going to be our special co-host
today our guest co-host
um to to join us
in rounding up the tweety tweets and the
trendy trends as we always do here on
the tony michaels podcast if we have any
new listeners out there which i know we
do we're gaining more and more new
listeners every single day
we broadcast every single weekday monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page so don't miss a
single episode and don't worry even if
you miss
an episode live just subscribe to the
tony michaels podcast here on youtube
you will find
those episodes here also go download
every single episode every single
episode monday through friday on
google spotify apple wherever you get
wherever you download your podcast
go download the tony michaels podcast
and don't forget tomorrow tomorrow's
friday
and you know what happens here on the
tony michaels podcast on friday we have
bonehead of the week
so today tonight
the boneheads will reveal themselves and
we will put out our bonehead of the week
poll on our twitter page at
tonymichaelspod so go follow us over on
twitter at tonymichaelspod.to vote
for bonehead of the week and then
tomorrow because you vote you decide who
is the bonehead of the week and me and
gabe break down in the second hour on
friday tomorrow
your vote for bonehead of the week gabe
will be back tomorrow
he will be back to his um his other
bunker i believe i think that's the plan
the bunker that he's at today the
undisclosed underground
bunker he is at today is
not affording him the amount of wi-fi
that he needs to stream here but
tomorrow he will be back in action
with appropriate wi-fi
so he'll he'll be joining us tomorrow
for bonehead of the week
but we have a we have a great guest
today i'm excited to have her on the
show now we've been talking about having
her on a show for weeks because she was
in these hearings
on the panel with us
but let me tell you something about the
select hearings
and how this is all shaping up because
you've noticed that the select committee
hasn't stopped
did you notice that they haven't stopped
like they've stopped the hearings right
but they're still
trickling stuff out little by little by
little by little
there's little things that they're
dropping here or there
just you know bits of
video deposition
that really kills the case
that somehow somehow
donald trump wasn't trying to overthrow
the government
i mean for weeks and weeks and weeks and
weeks donald trump said oh but but why i
tried to get ten thousand troop which is
a [ __ ] lie he did not try to get ten
thousand troops chris miller the acting
uh secretary of defense at the time
was deposed under oath
and unequivocally
i think i think literally that was the
question unequivocally
there was no order no official order
from trump to have
national guard
ready nope
not a thing no troops were
nope not a thing chris miller says nope
nope not a thing
doesn't exist no matter what i said on
fox news with sean hannity doesn't exist
doesn't exist it's actually the opposite
is true
that's that that
when trump says something when trump
says something it's it's the opposite
that's true
and and the media always plays into this
nonsense that's what what we see with
these saudis
joe biden gives a fist bump to the saudi
bonesaw prince
and the media loses their mind they ask
questions day after day after day in the
press briefing room
the press secretary
who is supposed to be giving briefings
for the american people on [ __ ] that
[ __ ] matters
like this veterans bill like the
inflation protection act
and they're asking questions about fist
bumping
and here the former president is hosting
the saudi golf tournament
not not a [ __ ] peep not a peep not a
peep
when is the media gonna pluck their head
out of their asses in this country and
realize
that fascism is at the front door
and it is the threat
joe biden fist
bumping
the saudi prince is not the thing that
is going to topple democracy that is not
the threat
really honestly uh drawing us out of
inflation with an intentional recession
here isn't a threat to our democracy
it gives us a lot of economic pain
for the snap back to a recession
but it's not the threat to our democracy
it's not the threat to our vote it's not
the threat to our way of life it's not
i've been saying this for months and
months and months that inflation is not
all bad
it's not all bad yes it's it's it hurts
certain people in the economy
but the opposite of inflation is
recession
that's that's what it is inflation
recession
they're two opposite things and to stop
inflation you need a recession
but recession hurts the people that
inflation hurts even more
and we let them take the narrative on
this [ __ ]
just like we let them take the narrative
on all kinds of things
but when we let them control the
narrative with gas prices high
joe biden fault
will we let them control the narrative
here
as the american people
they pressure the fed into raising the
interest rate because they don't want
inflation to get out of control
so
they inflate interest rates which cost
people more money than inflation
what the [ __ ] do you think interest
rates are
what the hell do you think they're gonna
do
they're gonna draw us into a recession
intentionally this recession that you're
seeing that's why most people aren't
even calling in a recession
because they're goading us into it
because the opposite of inflation is
recession that's their plan that's your
plan to stop inflation
to stop demand i'm i'm not kidding you
their plan to stop demand which drives
our economy
which in most cases at the end of the
day demand is better than no demand
regardless of if it's an inflating
economy or not
the middle class and the lower class in
this country count on demand and the
reason why is because the lower and
middle class almost the only capital
they have to [ __ ] bargain with is
their labor
that's it that's all you have to bargain
that's all you have to trade most folks
in this country don't have hundreds of
millions of dollars to go put in capital
and businesses they have their labor
they have their time
to trade in this capitalist society for
a wage
and those corporations should feel
should feel grateful we should not we
should not
be thankful for the corporations giving
us money for our labor
they should be thankful
for us giving our labor for the money
they're willing to pay us
and i think the american people woke up
during the pandemic that that is what
happens we trade our labor
and in an inflated economy
you have you have the demand to trade
your labor unemployment is almost
nothing
almost nothing
and the gdp is going down because of
interest rates
they're intentionally stopping demand
because demand will drive inflation
i don't know inflating wages inflating
the economy
dropping unemployment even more
but they want to scare you with high gas
prices and yeah it sucks i'm not saying
that that inflation isn't all easy it
isn't
it a changing economy is never easy
on the lower and middle class
never
no matter what the change is rather you
go from a recession to a to inflation or
inflation to recession
it's never an easy change it's never an
easy swing
for the lower and middle class because
all they have to trade is their labor
and in a recession guess what guess
what's not in demand that much in a
recession folks
guess what it is labor labor is not that
much of a demand in a recession
because demand is lower
so they don't need your labor as much
they'll start to lay you off
you'll start to see the help wanted
signs go out you'll start to see wages
drop again
the opposite of inflation is recession
that's why they're talking about it this
morning of course republicans oh jesus
they just they just can't stop
gaslighting people
oh joe biden with his bad economy now
it's a recession
well you were complaining about
inflation yesterday
the opposite of that is recession so you
should be happy now you were complaining
about inflation so you should be glad
that there's a recession for crying out
[ __ ] loud
america really does need to get back to
the bare bones of how our economy works
and stop letting politicians stop
letting corporations tell them how the
economy works
it's really simple
if you have capital to trade which is
your labor
you get to trade your labor to someone
for a wage or benefit sometimes
that's what that's your ability
in the economy
and that's why we see help wanting signs
everywhere
because those businesses that have
helped wanted signs in front of them
they're not willing to trade much money
for the labor that they need
so you're able to walk somewhere else
and trade your labor
for a higher wage
that's how it [ __ ] works
that's how it's always worked
but it really is rich that the nazis the
gop the gqp yesterday were really
concerned about about inflation and now
today now that oh it's the economy is
recessing of course it is they're
intentionally doing it by costing middle
and lower class more money by raising
interest rates everything that you're
going to buy is going to cost more
of course the demand is going to go down
people are going to start to save their
money
because they can't afford the interest
rates duh
no [ __ ] sherlock this isn't complicated
but now
yesterday they were concerned about
inflation today now they're concerned
about recession which they should be
excited about recession if they were
honest but they're not they're [ __ ]
liars and they're [ __ ]
definitely nazis stick around right
after the break we're gonna bring
jessica denson the trump nda killer
stick around don't go anywhere we will
be right back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
years bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live love and blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around to the break
the special guest for you today
you watch any of the january 6 select
hearing she was a star
in those hearings i enjoyed uh having
her during those hearings so much
and i've gotten to know her outside the
hearings uh smart
and boy
she is she is a fighter she is a fighter
she fought the trump nda from the trump
campaign she won
by herself in court
and it it reminds me when we're watching
these hearings when we watch cassidy
hutchinson and sarah matthews that these
young women
are going to save our country are going
to save our country regardless of their
political background their political
beliefs
they're the ones that are going to save
this country because they have integrity
and just like liz cheney
said in the very last hearing
these 50 60 year old men
are weak and they have to lie and
capitulate so welcome to the show
jessica denson jessica how are you
oh i'm doing great tony how are you oh
i'm i'm i'm on fire this morning
i am on fire this morning uh you noticed
that the uh the christian nationalists
in this country are young they're really
upset they're really upset that people
people are are referring to them as
nazis like what do you expect i i i want
to get to that here in a minute
the first thing i want to talk to you
about because we haven't had a chance to
talk about it since the hearing you were
with me every single hearing on those
panels right all eight
i think maybe seven i don't think i was
with you on the first
then like
i never left i never left you stayed by
your side the whole time i know i was
trying to count i was like she was there
i know she was there and you were you
were there in the front of the hearings
most the time you were there right in
the middle you were ready to give your
commentary and then at the very end you
were ready to give your commentary but
we haven't had a chance to discuss since
this last hearing that the season finale
as it was and because it sounds like
we're gonna have more hearings
um we haven't had a chance to discuss
the doj confirming that yes they are
investigating donald trump so tell me
what you make of that because we had a
lot of that conversation during those
hearings i remember specifically i don't
remember exactly which hearing it was
but you had a little back and forth even
with michael cohen about the department
of justice and rather they're going to
rather they're going to actually charge
an indict or they're investigating and
how that would work so tell me
give us a good sense of what you what
you see in that as far as the
confirmation of it
yeah i'm extremely grateful
i see that the doj is
i'm not going to pretend to know what's
going on inside that building none of us
really know
but you can't help but think and observe
that their confirmation
and the activity that's happening in the
grand jury is an effect of the work of
the january 6th committee these tracks
are happening in parallel in tandem
um and
i'm extremely grateful i think it shows
you how important the narrative is we
went through almost a year and a half
of gaslighting and attempted rewriting
of the narrative of what happened on
january 6th we went through almost a
year and a half
of republicans
using donald trump's big lie which was
not nabbed in the bud immediately
by trying to enact voter suppression
laws all over this country as they
continue to this day
and
finally we had the january 6th committee
hearings to flesh this out again to
bring back our memory to that day that
heinous day when donald trump tried to
overthrow american democracy and we saw
it in full relief and i think the
justice department
is feeling the heat
and i do not believe that donald trump
is above the law i never did believe it
if i believed it i could have never
taken him on in the courts he's a paper
tiger
and he just needs to be taken
down for what he's done it's pretty
simple if we're a rule of law society we
have the greatest criminal staring us in
the face living on a golf course in
florida making millions of dollars off
of those people that you were just
talking about the labor workers those
are the ones that fund donald trump
and we have his crimes in full relief
how could we possibly
not have the justice department bring
charges against him so
do i
uh
am i grateful absolutely um do i think
that
this is a byproduct of the work of the
january 6 committee absolutely um and i
i want us all i'm most likely going to
do it i say it all the time you know i
have this is how i feel tony we have to
keep the pressure we have to show our
public interest in demanding that donald
trump be charged for his crimes and that
it is not rewritten as a political
narrative that it never was
not political folks this man broke the
law if he doesn't go to jail we might as
well just open up the prisons in the
jails and let everybody out because
there is no standard for crime in this
country
so uh yeah i'm extremely grateful to see
this confirmation and i think that the
the pressure that has been exerted by
the january 6 committee in putting this
in full relief for the american public
and bringing so many people into the
light that didn't know about this before
that were have been gaslit or just
completely blinded to
donald trump's
efforts to overturn the election and
really do anything anything
um
to keep himself in power against the
will of the people um
you can't possibly uh move past this
with with with the attention of so much
of the country on this and seeing just
the inequity of having a man like donald
trump living as a free man in this
country
i couldn't agree with you more and if we
get news this morning that even the rnc
is terrified that he's going to try to
run to protect himself from indictments
here because that's the sense right is
that he he'll he may announce a run for
2024 to try to to try to stave off any
indictments that might happen because he
thinks he's going to be immune if he
runs for whatever reason which even
merrick garland has said no
and the department of justice says no
that's that's not how it works we will
indict you we will investigate you if
you are running we don't that doesn't
bother us but the rnc knows this
that if he does announce this year
during the midterms that trump is on the
ballot right he becomes on the ballot
which i am excited if trump actually
announces that he's running because now
we can get a clear picture of what the
electorate has to do like here's the
threat here's what he's wanting it's
pretty obvious now what he wants but i
don't think he'll do that and the reason
why is because the rnc has already given
him a check here said no we're not going
to pay your legal bills which
i think it was like 1.7 is the is the
tally total right now and this is even
personal legal bills from his business
in new york that the rnc is paying which
is not surprising i guess that
even even the rnc is grifting trump
supporters for money to give to trump
because he's so broke um
but
i will say
that
the other thing that really prevents him
from running here is his super pac that
he goes around and he grips off that
because he can't he can't have he can't
have a campaign
and a super pac he has to he has to have
one or the other he can do the super pac
thing or he can run for president he
can't do both now he can have the pack
but it's kind of separated at that point
and it just sounds to me like it would
be more crimes committed well what do
you make of
the rnc telling him
no we're not going to pay your legal
bills because i believe they're trying
to get him to not run what do you make
of it
oh they're scared to death of him
running they are scared to death nothing
motivates democrats and independents
more than donald trump on the ballot
right
right yeah they're they're terrified the
rest of us um
you're talking about you're talking
about super pacs and donald trump moving
money around this is something i know a
little bit too much about because i'm
litigating with these people
do you know how many first of all you
talked about his legal bills do you know
that
over a million dollars has been paid to
the law firm that is fighting me in
court
a million bucks a million dollars has
been paid
that is what happens when donald trump
raises money off the off the backs of
hard-working people they use those that
money to fund terrorism in the courts
against people like me
that's where their money goes
so um
yeah they have they have transferred
what used to be uh donald j trump for
america our donald i'm sorry donald j
trump incorporated to the make america
great again pac
now they are
not exactly being
explicit about their answers to their
finances i have two words for uh what it
may take us and what what the country
may need to do when it comes to donald
trump's finances and those are forensic
accountants
um
because i think that there is
quite a bit to be looked into into his
moving of money around between his
former campaign current campaign or
campaign entity and super pacs um save
america pack is one of them another one
that um may or may not have his direct
involvement as the make america great
again
again
pack there's all these different packs
which i think is actually not
technically tied to him i think that's
brad parscall and others but the save
america pack like you said is definitely
his his super pac
so um
yeah i've always thought that his his
threat to run let's put it that way
has been a
a fundraising tool right he's going to
continue to say it as long as he as long
as he can
to to continue siphoning money out of
his supporters
um
but on the same token and i don't know
the answer will he run won't he run i
don't i really don't know specifically
the answer but this man's ego is so big
and why has he always wanted to be in
power
he's wanted to be in power to avoid
criminal liability that's this is number
one motivation that was his number one
motivation for being president in the
first place and for uh running for
re-election to avoid criminal
accountability now here's the good thing
about the doj
policy that you know memo that we saw
circulate like it was some news scoop a
couple weeks ago
it's just a policy it is not law
it is a memo that is circulated uh every
almost every year by whatever sitting
attorney general is in the doj
and
amen we have had confirmation this week
i think i think merrick garland we have
we have you know sucked as much out of
this man as we possibly can because he
is a restrained individual we know this
he does not want to divulge things and
you know credit to him for that they
should not speak about active
investigations in the long run in the
long run it gives them credibility
um and and uh
gives them the the cover that they need
to to operate in a straight line and and
follow the facts but this man has said
as much as he possibly can to let us
know that a memo or any other thing is
not going to get in the way of him
prosecuting someone who's committed
crimes whether they're announcing or
running and and of course if donald
trump announces a run for president
that's 2024 we're in 2022 folks right
that's a long way off
so it's not going to affect if an
indictment's brought even in the next
year it's not not anywhere near his
potential election
so um you know if he can he can do
he can do whatever uh whatever the hell
he wants
justice is coming for donald trump i
really don't care if he runs or doesn't
run
if he runs it helps the democrats uh
and you know
we shall see we shall see how he figures
out how to move his money around and try
to avoid the law in his 11th hour
because that's what this is it's the
11th hour for donald trump
i think i think you're right and the
moving the money is important because i
think he is coming to the end of the
line here that's and and i think that's
you know what the super pac is that's
what him like you're saying teasing to
run uh to get them to buy more flags to
buy more hats give him more money i mean
he was actually fundraising
off his ex-wife's death
um a few weeks ago it was it's kind of
it really is
pathetic and you would think oh my gosh
how do these people you know how do they
fall for this and and what is it about
this that that makes them fall for this
which leads me to
this christian nationalism thing because
this populist christian nationalism
movement
um that marjorie taylor green is having
to go on right wing podcast and ask
answer the question which is
is astonishing to me and to answer the
question
are you a nazi like and she has to oh
she plays this you know this
this gaslighting trickery that somehow
she's offended when she's called and not
say well jessica
i i am not offended when i'm called a
nazi because i'm not one i'm just i'm
just not offended it doesn't affect me
that much and it really does seem like
with all this projection that's a reason
why they're so offended by this stuff
but i know this christian nationalism
these these people these fascists trying
to
uh appropriate christianity as their
tenement which is not even close
is is an issue that's near and dear to
your heart because of the things that
you've had to endure so tell us what you
make of this
this this news of these people calling
themselves
christian nationalist
tony where do i start with you
[Laughter]
all right so let me start here
white christian nationalism
you're either a white nationalist or
you're a christian right
you're not both you're not both
um you and i have talked a lot about the
bible i think you're
you're so interesting tony because you
call yourself an atheist but i think you
like to talk with me about the bible
more than most people i know i just
because i'm an atheist doesn't mean that
i don't i don't see cause that
that we should have that we should have
good conversations about this stuff
we have freedom of religion in this
country and that's what i think some of
these christian nationalists as they're
as they're calling themselves because i
don't believe they're christian either
just like you don't um i i'm an atheist
and i actually you know have more a
better moral standard than most people
who
in this nationalist movement who are
calling themselves this i i i follow the
teachings of the new testament more than
they do and i'm an atheist i know i know
but i i think i think it's important
what you're saying though is that yeah
is that
even even from my standpoint where i'm a
non-believer
i think it's important to have
conversations because i think you can't
shut people out um i i had this i had
this on one of my threads on twitter
when i posted this about uh marjorie
taylor green being a nazi
and they said why do you attack
christians so much you don't attack jews
you don't attack muslims i'm like well
the problem is is that jews and muslims
are not a domestic terrorism threat
and they're not using their religion in
a way that props up domestic terrorism
and promotes domestic terrorism you're
the one who are who who are bastardizing
the new testament the teachings of
christianity and using it
to prop up and to try to stoke domestic
terrorism so i believe in freedom of
religion and i believe that anyone in
this country should have the right to
believe what they want to believe to the
extent that they want to believe in what
book they want to believe it in whether
it's
or or not to believe
so that is that's why i'm so interested
and i love having conversations with you
about this because of that
yeah let's dive in let's dive into the
bible go ahead yeah let's do that
you want you want to know what the bible
says about nationalism
it says ye are no more strangers and
foreigners but fellow citizens with the
saints and of the household of god
what does evangelical mean tony you know
what evangelical means right absolutely
means of the gospel
preaching the gospel have these people
ever read the gospel i'm just wondering
have they read any of it let's keep
going uh galatians there is neither jew
nor greek there is neither bond nor free
there is neither male nor female for ye
are all one in christ jesus
whoa whoa easy jessica easy easy jessica
jessica you're gonna you're gonna really
piss off the far right pronoun people
that you know i think it's hilarious
this is the thing that happened the
other day the vice president kamala
harris they were they were they were
having a discussion there were there
were some folks that were blind in the
room so they were using words to
describe what
what those people were now a lot of
people even adam kinzinger this morning
is saying oh this is what's wrong with
the left and you know on and on and on
like why are you people so offended why
are you so offended
by words
this is this is it is it is um
and and they're going to be offended by
words in the bible just what you said
because what you just said what you just
said is that there aren't there isn't
male there isn't female that's that's
not right jessica that's not right these
pronoun these pronoun bros will tell you
that's not right
so how does that work
here's how it works here's how it works
a jesus was all about our spiritual
identity
okay
it's not material it's not sexual
has nothing to do with uh how many
stockpiles of weapons you have in your
house it's about spiritual
character it's about spiritual armor
you know you and i have talked about
this before we've talked about
this ludicrous notion that god and guns
go in the same sentence
i read an article this week and it was
you know i i'm i'm just i cringe every
time i hear either
cristo christo fascism
and i understand i understand the
historical context of that term okay
don't think i don't
or or every time now this week it's
christian nationalism
these oxymorons okay you're either
christian or you're fat or fascist
you're either christian or you're a
nationalist you're either christian or
you're a nazi you're not both okay
we talked i was telling you about the
weapons i read an article this week it
talked about this imposter christianity
okay and this is so important this is so
important because you don't have to be a
christian and if you're not a christian
that's that's your right that's what
that is the foundation of this beautiful
country our founding fathers many of
them who were christian or
protestant
some atheist
these men
these men
wrote a constitution with a bill of
rights the first amendment of that bill
of rights has an establishment clause
saying there shall be no established
religion and you know what you know
what's even more interesting to me about
this discussion not just
as a christian you know i hear this you
know we're a christian nation
i like to think we
from my understanding of christianity
that we imbibe
christian values the values that i
associate with christianity
but but that that's what that's the
problem with an established religion
in any free country who's to determine
whose brand of christianity are we
living
because my brand of christianity for one
tells me that my armor
is the shield of salvation the helm the
breastplate of righteousness the sword
of the spirit not a stockpile of ar-15s
and
so
this notion even as a christian
that that their version their
bastardized blasphemed version of
christianity
is what we are supposed to have as a
national religion
is appalling
it's appalling
and i i i've seen a lot of okay i'm i'm
i'm losing my train of thought but i
want to go back to this one thing
this christian posture
the article that i saw i was so happy to
see it because i'm like thank god
somebody is calling out this imposter
christianity and i read down
and it got to this section where it
talked about christian armor and i just
talked to you about christian armor you
and i have talked about this even on the
paddle we talked about it on a day where
we didn't even know that a lot of the
people in the january 6 hearing that
they were going to be testifying about
faith and it happened to be it was so
coincidental the whole the whole hearing
was about faith
it was it was the day that rusty bowers
bowers and
sheamus and ruby freeman it was the day
that these people talked about their
faith
being the thing
that allowed them to stand up against
donald trump
that's real faith that's real spiritual
armor and weaponry it has nothing to do
with bullets or ammunition
it has to do with standing for something
that is real
standing for truth standing for
principle standing for love that is
christian warfare
and this article that i read about being
an imposter christian it got to this
section where it talked about christian
warfare and it says you know we've had
hymns and christian religions for years
that i know i'm a christian i sing them
to there's really famous one it says
onward christian soldier marching as to
war with the cross of jesus going on
before
there was never a doubt in my mind in my
upbringing in my sunday school that that
christian armor
with spiritual armor
spiritual weaponry and this article
linked to the passage
in in the new testament
talking about the helmet of salvation
the breastplate of righteousness is said
and it linked to it but it said the
problem with these current so-called
white christian nationalists is they've
taken it was it was talking about the
people who have taken it to the level of
violence you know like some of the
insurrectionists who prayed
prayed before they went and erected a
gallows from mike pence
they said they've taken this literally
hell no they have not taken this
literally if you take it literally you
understand that it is telling you that
your warfare is spiritual not material
let's be clear and i say this i say this
and like i said if you're not a
christian that is fine that is you're
right this is a beautiful free country
and that is that is what makes us free
is that we have the freedom of
conscience
to think and and act at our best
understanding whatever that is
religion or no religion
but
to to for the christians today
there are so many christians who feel
like they have no home
in christianity anymore because of these
bigots these zealots these
anti-christians
who are literally forcing
the what i would call the real followers
of jesus that real evangels the ones who
are doing their best to live the gospel
out of the church
and these people feel like they have no
home
and i saw um i saw one i saw another
article where where this man who was a
either a minister or a
a preacher something something like that
he's talking about giving up
walking away from his own church because
he can't stand the other people who are
who are misrepresenting him
it is heartbreaking and it is it's
really important if you're not a person
of faith fine but if you are
don't walk away
do not let them take the banner of
christianity in that sacred text that
you love
donald trump walking across a a park
gassing protesters to hold up a bible
he's never read
give me a break you don't give up
christianity what you what what really
is christianity to you what you know it
to be in your heart you don't forsake it
to these nazis
that brings me to a great that brings me
to a great point i want to show you a
clip here that's going around twitter um
this is on some kind of traitor
podcast or something that michael
knowles show he had marjorie t he
welcomes her with open arms but listen
to the first question and listen to her
response to this first question here
thanks congresswoman green thank you so
much for coming on
thanks for having me on michael so first
question twitter is forcing me to ask
this
are you now or have you ever been
a nazi a national socialist i i i love
how he at first he wants to say nazi he
decides not to say nazi because he wants
to say the word socialist which this is
this is par for the course uh for this
stuff jessica where they're trying to
even they're trying to even rewrite
like what 1920s 30s and 40s nazis were
everyone knows that the national
socialist party that we know as nazis
weren't socialist like these these
people tried to mark people today
not even close not even what what the
aim was of the party but they do it
anyways because they have to rewrite
history they always have to
um whitewash as it were everything not
just like what you're talking with
christianity and and the actual
teachings of the bible they whitewash
those but they're here he's even
whitewashing the word nazi he can't even
he it can't even leave his lips the word
nazi until he has to turn and say
national socialist so let's listen to
her response
how
he asked her the question rather she's a
not national socialist
no never i'm relieved to hear that
yeah that apparently they can label you
things you're not and lie about you and
smear your character
on twitter and they think that's
perfectly okay
you know what's really funny jessica
here's a person that's all she does
that's all she does it's smear other
people's character
by the way you know what there's a
commandment for that it's called do not
bear false witness against thy neighbor
oh so there's something wait wait so
you're telling me in that book that she
claims her nationalism stands on there's
something against that in that in that
book is that is that what you're saying
oh yeah yeah
you know
that picture of her sitting there with
the bible reading the bible with the
glasses on did you see that one yeah
where she's in the recliner and she's
got all the crosses behind her or
whatever it is
yeah yeah you know what jesus has to say
about that or actually his his disciples
they say a man may say thou hast faith
and i have works show me thy faith
without thy works and i will show thee
my faith by my works you know this this
performative christianity is nothing new
it was all over the bible jesus was
calling out the hypocrites all the time
they were all about the show
all about the pictures of their worship
and their you know look at me bow down
to pray
spare me jesus had no patience for these
people no patience this goes back to his
time so this is nothing new i know
this is another thing actually that
someone someone pointed out to me and
i'm really grateful for it just the
other day because i i i know this but
sometimes we forget it this is not new
just like the nazi threat is not new
right these things repeat themselves
these these these challenges this
hypocrisy this hijacking of of real
character real courage you know what did
what did uh
donald trump and roger stone
the the words that they used on january
6 were courage courage
courage is like
gold it's like the sexiest thing i've
ever thought of is courage and they take
that word courage and they bastardize it
they use it for selfish gain for greed
for for self-seeking power and place in
this world again
everything that jesus
lived and hung on a cross
to be against
to represent the opposite of jesus was
the opposite of place and power in this
world
you're you're starting you're starting
to convert i'm just kidding um
yeah i always i always love hearing your
perspective but let's let's listen to
how she's deeply offended just i mean
absolutely deeply even and her family
and her constituents are hurt
that she is running around
promoting nazi tenements and people are
pointing it out calling her a nazi let's
listen
and this is what they have done to me
ever since i became a member of congress
and i'm really tired of it i i am i'm i
it hurts me it hurts my family
so quit that's what i think right like
if it hurts so bad if that's really the
the worst thing that could happen why
doesn't she quit that's what i think
are you changing your hat there let's
see what
you know i just i just really think it's
important to point out
how this whole shtick
you know it's a stick
it's all performance politics and and
and you know they act hurt but let me
tell you every time she goes on one of
them podcasts
she's raking in the dollars man i mean
they're coming she's fundraising off of
this awful poetry my friend
it's all performance politics
i think i think we need to call her by
her true name you know what that is
what is that
it's marjorie taylor greed
martin cole agreed
marjorie taylor greed why i agree with
you you know another person um you just
you triggered something in my brain here
because i know you probably have
witnessed this person walking around in
his in his fake fifteen thousand dollar
suits and now all of a sudden he grew a
beard and he wears flannel donald trump
jr um he really changed like he he went
from he went from mr new york city to mr
anti new york city i mean in a new york
minute i mean really fast he went from
having a beard wearing flannel he he
looks like he broadcasts from log cabins
because this isn't just her this
performance politics goes to bobert it
goes to so many of these people um
a lot of people have pointed out john
kennedy the senator from louisiana does
the same thing they they they take their
you know they really get deep into their
accents um
so
you're saying you're saying that this is
all bs and it's just a performance to
get to get uh to get contributions can't
main contributions is that what you're
saying
i'm saying that the entire platform of
the fascist right
the ones that like to tell all those
poor people in a bible belt middle
america that that the snowflakes out in
hollywood
can't take the truth
can't handle free speech
you know what
all these people are want to be actors
every single one of them
taylor green
don jr
his uh oh my god almighty kimberly
whatever foil her name is
oh my gosh
yes ingram
josh
holy steve oh what's his name sean
hannity
these people are all actors
they just get on television every night
and they put on an act because that act
makes them one hell of a hell of a lot
of money
you know that's
bringing up uh making an act and have a
lot of money there's
there's a there's a gubernatorial
candidate a republican
in pennsylvania running against josh
shapiro who is a jewish american by the
way
um
but
he's really he's really diving deep into
this and he's using the gab ceo
um to really help him out with his
messaging and it really does it really
does smell anti-semitic
maybe maybe i'll play a little bit here
and we can talk about now again this guy
down here at the bottom let me move my
banner this guy down here at the bottom
that's the gab ceo
and he's uh what he's doing is he's
commenting on
uh a report from andrea mitchell and
about
josh shapiro and the race with i think
his name is uh mastriano but we'll call
him we'll call him mussolini for now for
for the time being well let's listen to
what the gab ceo has to say
about this race but more specifically
about the nationalism that we've been
talking about here
bud this is a christian nation
christians outnumber you by a lot a lot
and we're not gonna listen to
two percent
you represent two percent of the country
okay we're not bending the knee to the
two percent anymore
the 98
of the rest of us you know 70 75 of
which are christians self-identifying
christians
we're not taking it anymore bud
we are taking back our culture we're
taking back our country we're taking
back our government
so uh deal with it
you know there's nothing you can do to
stop us because what has uh been set
into motion
it's uh it's snowballing now right it's
not we have marjorie taylor green openly
saying that she's a christian
nationalist we have matt gates kind of
uh flirting with it a little bit today
with his his tweet on christian
nationals it's always a bad it's always
a bad look when anyone says mac ass is
flirting with anything by the way that's
a really bad look that's really bad for
that narrative but i'll digress
um
uh you know we paul gosar we have like
people in congress right now members of
congress right now who are openly openly
saying that they're christian
nationalists uh we have multiple
candidates for governor who won their
primaries in the landslide uh are
winning in the polling right now and are
going to win the governorships of
multiple states who are christian okay i
can't take it anymore um here's what
i'll tell you about this my quick
opinion of this is this guy sounds
scared is what he sounds like he sounds
a little terrified and he's using he's
using this this self-proclaimed
nationalism and matt gatz and margie he
named three people in congress that he
can that he can think of in a couple
governor's races that are
self-proclaimed and i love that he he
actually he actually said
self-proclaimed christians not actual
christians just self-proclaimed i mean i
mean jessica i'm an astronaut i'm an
astronaut i'm self-proclaimed i'm an
astronaut so i am an astronaut it's
funny how they make fun of people and
they they push back on people they're
like oh you can't just call yourself
something and you are that you can't
just call yourself a woman you can't
just call yourself a man you can't just
call yourself this you can't just use
these pronouns but here they are
self-proclaimed christians it's really
funny
yeah i can't listen to them either
because you know what this i was
watching this uh
i was watching this this show last night
called under the banner of heaven have
you heard of it no what is it what is it
on so it's a it's a true crime story i
mean it's it's dramatized a little bit
but it's on it's on hulu which by the
way cancel your subscription because
they wouldn't
air an at an anti-fascist uh ad for the
democrats so
sorry hulu but i'm not feeling good
about you right now but it's
it's
um
but it's a great show
creator dustin lance black who did milk
um
he actually came from a mormon family
this is about mormonism and okay i i've
said this before like in passing i'm not
mormon i have a lot of issues with
mormonism i think it's a cult
but um
i have learned oh my god from this
series so many things about the mormon
religion that i did not know before
and um
i've also really gleaned from it
just the misogyny oh my god the misogyny
that is baked in to
the mormon religion but also
you know this brand of fun
fundamentalist christianity let's let's
call it let's call it just
fundamentalism let's not even call it
christianity you know whatever amy comey
barrett follows just fundamentalism
fundamentalist cultists is what they are
not christians
um that would that would really set
woman
back to being chattel to being property
of man i mean that's that's what we when
i hear these men
it's so disgusting it's so disgusting
because because you know these men i
mean we saw i think you probably played
it or gabe might have done a
clip about it a few weeks back
one of these
so-called christian preachers out there
giving this this just
repulsive speech about how women need to
submit to their husbands and submit to
men
yeah well we played it i i try to i try
not to let our audience look away you
have to see this stuff
it's disgusting it is absolutely
disgusting and i'm going to take it back
to the bible for a minute my friend i'm
sorry i gotta do this
in in the gospel
in the experience of jesus christ the
master christian if you are if you are a
believer
women are elevated
jesus christ elevated women time after
time
um
they
it was a woman it was first at when the
stone was rolled away to see jesus i
mean mary magdalene had such a such a
powerful role in the story of jesus
um
the story of the woman coming to wash
his feet him showing the humility and
this is really humility is really one of
the highest qualities of mankind
he was constantly pointing out
the higher and we've talked about this
before the higher uh
you know realm that that the feminine
nature abides in
and so the notion the notion that a
woman
um in today's
society would regress and have to be
subject to man and have to pass through
man to have her rights asserted or to
have her voice heard or to see if she's
able to control her own body her own
destiny her own salvation
um
is so disgusting you have men like josh
hawley
who who
what a pansy this guy this guy is such a
prick and a man like him a twerp like
him who was such so
intellectually dishonest and he people
like him get me the most
because this man is educated he knows
what he's doing and he comes out and now
he's on some some crusade for
masculinity josh hawley give me a break
this is the best thing to do
that is the best they can do speaking
speaking of masculinity and this toxic
masculinity stuff
i
i saw a video this morning outside a
courthouse of alex jones now the only
reason why this made me think
of some things that we were probably
going to talk about today is exactly the
exchange here it's not very long but
it's going to lead me into our next
topic um but watch this clip of alex
jones here finishing his cigarette you
know as as manly as that is
but but listen
listen to
him describe
you know describe why he's on trial and
why it's the journalist's fault who's
filming him here listen to this [ __ ]
so i'm almost done here
so uh
you pretend to be a journalist
and you want to look at people like me
so you can say you're the good guy i
think i think you're on trial though
right
for not having the corporate media is on
trial and so is the rig judiciary here
but you literally today
oh it's pathetic isn't it it's so
pathetic it's funny because it leads me
into my next topic that i want to ask
you about because you know a thing or
two about these alex jones characters
and the one specifically i'm talking
about is the walking scab that's still
kind of walking around um he was
we we solved this last week he he went
to court the judge made him go to trial
it didn't take very long because he
didn't have much of a defense which uh
he's
i don't know who would ever defend him
in the first place but i'm talking about
uh scabby steve bannon that's what i
refer to him as here but you you know
steve a little bit you know a little bit
about him you have a little history with
steve so tell us any updates or anything
you can tell us about steve
bannon uh the the
the new alex jones as it were let's hear
it
all right tony you don't mind if i go
back into performance politics mode
absolutely when you're talking about
other performance politics let's perform
all right all right so this is the
number one thing you need to understand
about steve bannon
now he may look like he has not showered
in a hundred years
but what's more important to understand
is that steve bannon could buy himself a
hundred golden showers to shower in if
he wanted to
this man is a multi-millionaire
you know how much he's worth tony
i i do not i'm sure you're going to tell
us though estimated 48 million
48 million dollars
here's what i learned about steve bannon
on the trump campaign all right you know
i was a true believer i was uh poor
jessica because she she was he was
drinking the kool-aid she thought these
people were real freedom fighters and
steve bannon was one of them you know he
said you know remember the um oh gosh
what was it the motto for for uh
breitbart remember what it was
what was it honey badger don't give a
[ __ ]
honey badger don't give a [ __ ] you know
what i thought i thought you know when
you're fighting for freedom you gotta be
like that you gotta pull out all the
stops you got to be a fighter
nobody else is willing to do it and
these these good men
donald trump steve bannon they're
willing to fight for freedom oh yeah
with what i learned about steve bannon
so i come on the trump campaign
here i am you know my my
my daddy's from ecuador by the way
in case you're wondering just some white
girl talking about hispanic engagement
my dad's from ecuador
so i come on the trump campaign and uh
and and steve bannon sees me i'm i speak
spanish i translate for him he's like
we need you to do hispanic engagement
and i'm like oh look this liberal media
out here they think
they think we're racist they think we're
white supremacy i got steve bannon here
he's he is promoting me to be the
hispanic engagement director these
people ain't racist
here's what it really goes to
these people use the racists they even
use the racist the white supremacists
the white nationalists they use these
people they dog whistle them
see bannon don't give a damn about any
of this
see bannon's got a picture behind him
during his podcast of that man we were
talking about jesus christ
i'm going to tell you one thing there's
only one god
it's the abandoned worships and it's the
almighty dollar
everything that steve bannon does
every performative
political word that comes out of his
mouth
is to put money in his own pocket
his god is greed that's why him and
marjorie taylor greed get along so well
because they worship the same god and it
ain't god
so when you think about steve bannon you
think about what he's doing with donald
trump
i got three words for you
quid pro quo
these are transactional men who
understand how they work for each other
when steve bannon left the white house
and he made those comments about donald
trump that made him fall out of donald
trump's good graces
you damn well better believe steve
bannon was finding a way to get himself
back
back into the money train right back
into the gravy train
and and on the same side he knows trump
and trump knows him
they know how each other thinks
and and he got himself to a point where
donald trump needed him
donald trump didn't need him didn't he
he needed him to build that army for
january 6 to lie to the people i mean he
was telling the truth on that audio that
leaked a few weeks ago wasn't he he knew
they all know it's a lie they all know
it's a play it's a game it's performance
it's acting
they tell the actors to stay out of
hollywood and the singers to shut up and
sing and the athletes to just you know
dribble
these people are 100 percent performance
politicians that is all they are
they don't have a true bone in their
body when they speak about freedom when
they speak about justice and courage
so steve bannon knew donald trump
donald trump knew steve bannon you know
what steve bannon did he went out
started his own
non-profit nonprofit gimmicks right
citizens of the american republic and
you know what steve bannon does he does
this schtick that they all have all the
people on the far right right
the the ones that are the for for the
people for the forgotten man for the
working man right they tell you that
that
it's the donor class the donor class of
politicians is controlling politics well
well that's true that's true but here's
here's the clincher the total class is
also funding steve bannon
[Laughter]
the american republic made millions of
dollars from the donor class
so here he is railing against the donor
class the deep state
deep state can we talk about deep state
for a minute tony we can talk about the
deep state i'd love to talk about the
deep state talk about deep state because
i'm sorry are we supposed to believe
that people that work years
for
i don't know 40 50 60 000 a year working
years just to get a government pension
these people
are conspiring to overthrow american
freedom
to spy on us to take away our rights and
and and and donald trump and the
criminal elites who were doing
multi-million billion dollar deals with
the saudis his children jared ivanka oh
no they're not the deep state why would
they have any why would they have any
motivation to to
to use and corrupt their power no it's
the bureaucrats
bureaucrats have got to show up every
day from eight to five their whole life
for decades just to get a government
pension that's the group say that makes
sense right
makes total sense well i'm glad you
brought up
the quid pro quo and the performative
politics of steve bannon because
if you need no more evidence of this
performance politics when he's in the
courtroom the last couple weeks he
absolutely shuts the [ __ ] up he says
nothing they have no defense and the
reason why i want i want to give the
audience a sense
when you're inside of a federal
courtroom especially when it's a
criminal proceeding
anything that you're going to say inside
that courtroom if you're convicted the
next magistrate that gets to sentence
you they will hold anything and
everything that you said in that
courtroom against you while you're being
sentenced steve bannon is looking at
possibly two years of a sentence now i
don't i don't think the judge will
actually give him two years i hope they
give him 15 18 months that's my hope
some think 60 days in in jail but i'm oh
i'm hoping at least 15 to 18 months
sentence here
now as soon as steve bannon's
scabby little ass
leaves the the the threshold of the
courthouse door he gets in front of a
microphone and he says how tough he is
and how great he is and how much he's
he's going to kick their ass and take
names and whatever the hell he says you
know and he's going to kill the deep say
just what alex jones the bluster that
alex jones says here we know
just in the last week alex jones didn't
show up to his jury selection because he
had medical issues and this guy's
clearly clearly standing outside the
courthouse he's he's of his own autonomy
he can smoke a cigarette and he can
banter back and forth to a journalist
but he can't attend a jury selection
it's all performance just what you're
saying it's all [ __ ] the whole thing
and it's all for their audience it's all
for their audience it's not for us like
the people who are onto them that's not
who it's for they don't give a [ __ ]
rather we're on to them or we're not
onto them they have to hold their
audience together because that quid pro
quo
is very important in that in that aspect
because the reason why steve bannon
still is doing his trade or tv network
thing and i want to get back to marjory
taylor green here in a second because
you brought her up but steve bannon the
reason why the reason why
they're a little afraid here is that
steve bannon is going to lose that
microphone
that microphone was part of the quid pro
quo
when when donald trump pardoned steve
bannon from the federal crimes of the
build the wall uh
fundraising where he defrauded all those
people it wasn't a grift it was a fraud
when he when he defrauded all that money
from those people he was gonna go to
federal prison and donald trump said hey
i will pardon you but guess what you
have to do now you have to do the
performative politics and that's all the
contempt charge was that's all that was
the reason why steve bannon is one of
the only i mean there's there's a few of
them but the reason why steve bannon is
one of the ones that didn't actually go
in and be deposed is because donald
trump did the quid pro quo you're not
allowed steve you're not allowed to go
in there you're not allowed to go in
there i pardon you you have to do what i
say or else
and that's why steve bannon yells and
screams into a microphone that's why he
acts tough that's why that's why he
activates the deep darks parts of the
web that go back to his days at
breitbart and his days with the mercers
that you brought up of course of course
it's all performance if it wasn't
performance steve bannon would be in
more trouble because if if his toughness
was real he'd have tried to be tough in
court and that judge when they do
sentence him would sentence him even
harder and he knows it he knows the
truth and the truth is that steve you
really got to look for a different soap
it's
it's something that exfoliates or
something jesus christ it's really bad
like you know i i wish i had better skin
and took care of my skin a little but
god damn this is ridiculous i actually
saw a picture
can i call you jesse with the gold head
on jess yeah okay jesse i saw i saw a
picture the other day of steve bannon
when he was actually in the military
right when this guy took an oath in the
military he did not look like he does
now i'm telling you what hatred and
alcohol will do us we'll do a hell of a
job on a person but steve if you're
listening out there because you might be
watching this because jessica i don't
know because jessica's here steve if
you're watching this
really honestly man pick a different
soap maybe get like one of them them
scrub they got that like at wally world
they got them scrub bars that you can
use on your face you can kind of you
know exfoliate and get the i don't know
i'm just saying take a shower every once
more that's all i'm saying that's all
and and enough of the four or five
shirts everyone knows that's performance
too but jessica jessica back to the
marjory taylor green
aspect of this
because i i actually think that steve
bannon is expecting to go to jail um
rather it's 30 days 60 days or it could
be 15 to 18 months i actually think that
that's probably uh likely a likelihood
that the judge will sentence him because
of his actions and because of his
behavior well i and because of his past
history now even though he was pardoned
i i really think that they will actually
uh sentence him to 15 to 18 months
somewhere in that range hopefully more
but maybe a little less than that i
think that's actually what he's going to
get sentenced to right before the
midterm and that's terrifying trump
that's terrifying all the people that
that steve bannon is holding together
with this coalition of trolls as it were
basically these manga trolls and
actually i think that's what marjorie
taylor green is doing with her show is
she's trying to prepare to step into
steve bannon's shoes here um because she
likes to activate that's what the that's
what the all the self-proclaimed
christian nationalism and all this stuff
is is she's trying to work her way into
this situation where she can basically
co-opt steve bannon's audience because i
know you know a thing or two about steve
bannon's audience as he's probably
turned them on you um but i think that's
really what what marjorie taylor green
and what what their goal is with her is
to actually co-opt steve bannon's
audience and continue that micro being
in front of that microphone that's why
she's all in for trump i mean it's
really discussing some of the stuff she
says but but anyways
how do you view
give me your insight not just on steve
bannon's show and how important it is to
him that he has that microphone because
without that i mean really steve bannon
is nothing but a walking scab and a
dirty jacket but tell us tell us your
insight on what that show is because i
know you have really deep insight
because you've served this person
you've served him speaking of an
audience speaking of an audience this is
for you midas margie no more accent for
you midas margie
[Music]
i really i i do that because it's
it really offends me and i hope i didn't
offend anybody with that accent i
certainly didn't mean to i just i'm
trying to point out the hypocrisy the
hypocrisy of these people and before we
get into marjorie taylor green's podcast
and her take in the taking the role from
steve bannon
i have traveled this country a lot i
have had you know we have these
conversations on these panels a lot of
times we're in an echo chamber we're
talking to you know people who are on
our side but i have had
many many of these conversations
one-on-one you know with people
in the bible belt with people along
interstates across america i have spent
a lot of
my past 10 years in the in middle
america traveling a lot
and
you know these are
these are good hard-working people this
is what really this is this is what so
infuriates me
because we we spend a lot of time
ridiculing them and that is not what i
was trying to do i was trying to point
out the hypocrisy of the people that use
them
that use these mechanisms to try to
relate to them and to to siphon their
hard-earned money the money that they
work day in and day out for that they
you know
put blood sweat and tears to put to put
food on the table and care for their
families and their children and people
like steve bannon and marjorie taylor
green use these people
and i have met them and they have yeah
they have some pretty heinous political
views they live in the vortex that i
used to live in this right-wing echo
chamber where they're told to disbelieve
everybody else
just believe your idols on the right
disbelieve everybody else
and
and these are the kind of people and i'm
not talking about i'm not talking about
the the hateful ones i'm not talking
about the greedy ones i'm talking about
the ones that if you broke down on
interstate 40 in the middle of the night
would stop there and you know spend
their whole night with you to get you
off the road that would that are that
are really good samaritans that are
really you know we're talking earlier
about being a real christian that really
are doing their best to be good humans
and good americans
and there are a lot of these people
who have been taken by these criminal
elites these criminal elites who go out
there
and rail against who they say are the
elites out there the democrats the
hollywood liberals the snowflakes
they are the elites they are the
criminal elites
steve bannon is the criminal elite he's
using you donald trump is the criminal
elite
you're funding his life on a golf course
you're funding you know when i finally
got steve bannon served the service that
he's trying to ignore that we're about
to file a precipice this week to to you
know certify our motion of contempt
because he never responded to that
either you know where i found him i
found him getting out of of course a you
know an excursion
having his driver you know pull his bags
up to his townhouse in capitol hill
that's worth millions of dollars that's
the life these people live
they don't know they they haven't lived
a struggle
for a long time but they sure are using
the people that are living the struggle
they're using them they're using them
and it's sickening it is so so sickening
so well i'll tell you
speaking of that um
there's actually something in the news
here that i i want to show you and i
want to get your response on of this
using using a group of people by you
know having the flag and and saying
support the troops and all this stuff um
the senate republicans
blocked the
um pact act which is the act is and jon
stewart the comedian has been
an advocate for this
for a long time you know that he helped
the 911 uh survivors the first responder
survivors and their effort in congress
and he has used his microphone to help
um the folks
that were exposed to toxic substance and
burn pits
uh in in the war the 20-year war that we
fought
and this pac act is supposed to
designate funds through the va
to give these people treatment that they
so need
and the republicans have blocked it now
jon stewart in
great fashion actually this morning um
went on
newsmax
and i i believe this is a true service
that jon stewart does because a lot of
people would not dare to appear
on newsmax and i think he's speaking
outside somewhere else too but
um when he went on newsmax this morning
he really picked apart the republicans
and why
why they
were trying to block this act because
it's all lies just like you're saying
now they're using lies to manipulate
veterans they're using lies to
manipulate rule folks they're using lies
to manipulate what you would think of as
ronald reagan supporters
but here this morning let me see if i
can
i'm having just a bit of trouble finding
i don't have my producer to get you're
kind of our guest host here so uh bear
with me here we go here's here's the
clip on newsmax walking through it tony
what's yours yeah here's here's the
newsmax clip um
of john stewart
talking about the lies that republicans
are trying to feed to the american
people about this act that will actually
deliver healthcare real healthcare
that's life-saving
to these veterans to veterans
not just like you know they they served
here they these are the ones who were
exposed to toxic chemicals in burn pits
they were working hard in burn pits
following orders
but let's listen to jon stewart and
him unpack the lies that republicans are
telling just like what you were saying
with the other stuff um but i did want
to point out just to push back a little
bit on this so the republicans
when you you say what you said
they do not support veterans
the republicans push back saying there
is unrelated spending
uh within this uh it's not it's just not
true
what they're saying is they don't like
that it's mandatory as opposed to
discretionary there isn't unrelated
spending to it
they're saying there could be if there
was an oversight but that's what the
senate's job is the bill itself is
incredibly detailed and prescriptive
about what it's for it's about treating
and preventing the uh different
conditions that veterans are coming home
with including cancers and chronic
bronchiolitis and all these other issues
from their exposures in iraq and
afghanistan
and i want to point something out here
um because jon seward does such a great
job at describing what the senate is and
and isn't doing and jon stewart has
always been a very good student of
government if you if you go back to his
days when he had the daily show and he
would listen to him he he understood the
functions of government he understood
the mechanisms of government
but john john is talking about mandatory
verse discretionary and what he's saying
is is the reason why republicans don't
like this is because that money is
actually going to be delivered it is
mandated to be delivered to those
veterans not discretionary meaning well
this money is just kind of up in the air
it's supposed to be for this but we
might be able to snag it and pay for
this thing over here that's what the
republicans don't like about it they're
not saying and they're they're lying to
their supporters by saying oh this
doesn't actually pay for these things
which is the total opposite they
actually do not want this bill to lay
out in detail exactly what it's supposed
to spend this money on and the reason
why is because then they can't snatch it
away from this bill it's despicable but
let's let's continue his explanation
here because he talks about slush funds
and i think this is important to push
back on what they're saying they're
saying
what if this creates a slush fund right
so are you familiar with something
called the oco the overseas contingency
operations fund fairly yes
fairly
right right yeah 50 billion
billion 70 billion
is added to what's called the oco on top
of the 600 billion 700 billion 800
billion that goes to the defense
department that oco fund is actually a
slush fund 60 to 70 billion dollars
every year no oversight no guard rails
and every one of those republicans that
voted against health care for veterans
voted for the slush fund for the war
they don't support the troops they
support the war military industrial
complex that's right and and he does
such a great job of pointing it out here
is that that jessica is just what you're
saying and it's not just one issue it's
all of them it's all of them and and i
am so happy to see
jon stewart's face on newsmax delivering
the message to their audience that hey
they're just [ __ ] lying to you and
and the best part is jessica that he's
got his cell phone out he's got a hat on
he's in a car he's pulled over on the
side of the road he's not in some fancy
studio or something like that that you
would expect the hollywood elite the
comedian to be in
he he is doing the work on the ground
and not just for this he did it for the
911 uh first responders and survivors
for those for those pieces of
legislation that he really tried to push
through and there's tons of video of him
testifying before congress but him
standing outside and and if i can find
another video but give me your insight
into what you feel
that this this does to move the needle
forward um on this bill i don't know if
it changes these republicans mind
apparently to me uh pat toomey um and
the senator from pennsylvania is the one
who tuck tailed and ran on this and
actually pulled 25 republicans with him
tell us what you think about the
this
this pack act and then abandoning it
it's disgusting it's just it's
disgusting it just shows you i mean
we're talking this whole pod about
performance politics and hypocrisy and
these republicans have always this is
another thing that they have gotten away
with hijacking the veterans platform you
know care for our service members
they do when it comes to
really doing something that our veterans
really need to save their lives to you
know give them what we owe them they
cannot even come forward they can fund
the
the military-industrial complex but they
cannot fund the well-being of our
veterans who are suffering
this is who these people are i don't
know i don't know i mean it's one of
those things like you can't get them to
like you know vote for
the most basic things like
you know
anti-lynching bill you would think it
would just be basic but these this is
who they are this is who they are so
even even even the human trafficking
bill
20 republicans including matt gatz who
is in under investigation for human
trafficking voted no for it
and and it goes back to why are we
allowing these narratives really
honestly that's what i i've always
believed and that's why i yell into this
microphone two hours every day is to try
to capture the narrative back and get
people to get out there and engage in
democracy and capture the narrative
oh my god the midterms i mean like just
the democrats are are have their they
have their platform written for them
they don't have to go digging for it
it's everything man everything is on the
line in 2022
freedom is on the line veterans rights
are on the line women's rights rights of
marginalized people like every single
freedom to live in america as an
american is on the line in 2022 so you
damn well better get behind democrats
and by the way you mentioned this vanity
project in the in the beginning this
vanity project third-party nonsense
right
i'm sorry wasn't wasn't andrew yang's uh
motto math
does this understand math
if you have a third party it's going to
siphon away votes from the existing
party that's just math buddy right and
we don't we don't need to again
we can we can we can make sure to cast
andrew yang out out with the rest of
them that are trying to steal our
democracy it is something we can do a
lot of democrats and a lot of people
like andrew yang but that's okay we can
we can tell you just the way it is
andrew yang is doing a thing that is
hurting democracy it's hurting democracy
and whether you believe it or not or you
want to believe it
it doesn't make it untrue now i i'm
getting um this video here now this is a
pretty long video jessica but this is
apparently uh i i watched earlier
senator gillibrand talk about this issue
but jon stewart actually goes after
america first here and maybe he says
some things exactly what we're saying
let's take a peek
scientist a [ __ ]
ain't this a [ __ ]
america's heroes
who fought in our wars
outside sweating their asses off
with oxygen
battling
all kinds of ailments while these
[ __ ] sit in the air
conditioning walled off from any of it
they don't have to hear it
they don't have to see it
they don't have to understand that these
are human beings do you get it yet
do we see that these are these aren't
heroes
these are men and women mothers and
fathers sisters and brothers
that we just let stand outside in the
heat
when they can't breathe
i'm going to read you something this is
beautiful this is a i'm going to read
you something beautiful you know what i
said a curse word and i'm sorry about
that that was my fault
i like it i like it
this is a tweet from senator rick scott
of florida this should be from yesterday
it's beautiful and i'm sorry about the
cursing and let me say something
beautiful to make it up to you
i was honored to join the uso today
and make care packages
for our brave military members in
gratitude
in gratitude jessica i think jon stewart
is going to say exactly what we've been
saying for the last half an hour what do
you think i think that's what we're
that's what we're preparing for here is
that he's going to talk about rick
scott's performance performance in this
tweet oh man
bring it bring it can i just take a
moment of personal privilege with jon
stewart here yeah sure if you know
anything of if you've heard my story on
the midas podcast you know i went to
george washington university yeah when i
was a student there these were days of
crossfire okay so oh yeah yeah tucker
carl oh yeah there's no one who hates
tucker more than jon stewart on
crossfire and they they filmed crossfire
from our school of media and public
affairs literally right on our campus
and while i was a student i would go and
like go around with my camera and report
on things jon stewart came to our alumni
weekend and he was the he was the
featured uh performer
and
it was right after he had put an end to
tucker
[ __ ] excuse my language no no no you
can you can say whatever the [ __ ] you
want here and it didn't work
like that either but
i was there i was there when jon stewart
put it into that [ __ ]
that's fantastic
and it was it was great it was great um
he yeah he is and you know what i mean
this just shows like you know jon
stewart
sean penn people that are you know
hot they're artists they're artists
and by the way
being an artist is a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing you and gabe do
this you you have the creativity in the
mind
because what is an artist an artist is
someone who has is searching and
yearning for truth
that is the real heart of an artist
right we use all these creative
mechanisms to get to the truth
so i'm so sick and tired
of these right-wing performance
politicians going after people who have
heart
like jon stewart who has used his comedy
to get to the truth
to actually
pursue a higher good
yeah juan stewart's great he's well
let's let's hear what what he says about
rick scott's performance because i'm
sure that's exactly what he's going to
talk about here
of their sacrifice
and service
to our nation and there's a beautiful
picture i wish you could see it he's
standing with a little package did you
get the package it's like you think it
has m m's in it
and some cookies
and some moist towelettes
i i don't even know honestly i don't
even know what to say i've been coming
down here 10 15 years i'm used to the
hypocrisy
christina keane will tell you from bfw
they she sat in an office with mitch
mcconnell
and a war veteran from kentucky and he
looked that man in the eyes and he said
and he lied to him
because mitch mcconnell yesterday
flipped
i'm used to the lies
i'm used to the hypocrisy
senator pat toomey won't take a meeting
with the veterans groups
sends out as chief of staff i'm used to
the cowardice i've been here a long time
senate's where accountability goes to
die these people don't care they're
never losing their jobs they're never
losing their health care pat toomey
didn't lose his job he's walking away
god knows what kind of pot of gold he's
stepping into
to lobby this government to [ __ ] on more
people
i'm used to all of it
but i am not used to the cruelty
they passed it
june 16th they passed the pact act
84 to 14. you don't even see those
scores in the senate anymore they passed
it
every one of these individuals that has
been fighting for years standing on the
shoulders of vietnam veterans who have
been fighting for years standing on the
shoulders of persian gulf war veterans
fighting for years desert storm veterans
to just get the health care and benefits
that they earned from their service and
i don't care if they were fighting for
our freedom i don't care if they were
fighting for the flag i don't care if
they were fighting because they wanted
to get out of a drug treatment center or
it was jail or the army i don't give a
[ __ ]
they lived up to their oath
and yesterday they spit on it
in abject cruelty
these people thought they could finally
breathe
you think their struggles end because
the pact act passes
all it means is they don't have to
decide between their cancer drugs and
their house
their struggle continues this bill does
a lot more than just give us health care
gives him health care gives them
benefits lets them live
keeps veterans from going homeless keeps
veterans from becoming addicts keeps
veterans from committing suicide
senator toomey's not going to hear that
because he won't sit down with this man
because he is a [ __ ] coward
you hear me
a coward
and like i say i'm used to it
but this type of cruelty on those that
we say
we hold up
as our most
valued americans
then what are we
pat toomey stood up there patriot pat
toomey excuse me i'm sorry i want to
give him his propers i want to make sure
that i give him his propers
patriot pat toomey stood on the floor
and said this is a slush fund they're
going to use 400 billion dollars to
spend on whatever they want that's
nonsense i call [ __ ]
this isn't a slush fund you know it's a
slush fund the oco the overseas
contingency operations fund 60 billion
dollars 70 billion dollars every year
on top of 500 billion 600 billion
dollars 700 billion dollars of a defense
budget that's a slush fund unaccountable
no guard rails did pat toomey stand up
and say this is irresponsible the guard
rails
no not one of them did they vote for it
year after year after year you don't
support the troops you support the war
machine
that's all you care about
proclamation to send me to war
boy they haven't they haven't met a war
they won't sign up for and they haven't
met a veteran they won't screw over
what the [ __ ] are we
and now they're gonna go away uh pat
toomey says uh i've got veterans groups
behind me i call [ __ ]
these are the veterans groups
vfw american legion iaba wounded
warriors dav and vets they're all here
this is the veterans community senator
they don't stand behind you in fact you
won't let them stand in front of you
cowards all of them
cowards all of them
and now they say well this will get done
maybe in the after we get back from our
summer recess maybe during the lame duck
because they're on senate time do you
understand you live around here senate
time is ridic these [ __ ] live
to 200.
they're tortoises
they live forever and they never lose
their jobs and they never lose their
benefits and they never lose all those
things well they're not on senate time
they're on human time cancer time
don't you have families
don't you have people
who are deciding how to live their last
moments i know some of them they've been
down here advocating with us they spent
their remaining time advocating so that
other soldiers didn't have to face the
indignities and the depravity and the
desperation that they faced and none of
them will hear it
and none of them care
except to tweet boy they'll tweet it
can't wait to see what they come up with
on veterans day on memorial day well
this is the reality of it
i
i honestly don't even know what to say
anymore but we need your help because
we're not leaving
these people cannot go away i don't know
if you know this you know obviously i'm
not a military expert i didn't serve in
the military but from what i understand
you're not allowed to just leave your
post
when the mission isn't completed
apparently you take an oath you swear an
oath and you can't leave
but these folks can leave because
they're on senate time go ahead go home
spend time with your families because
these people can't do it anymore
so they can't leave until this gets done
because these people will not give up
they will not give in and they will not
relent this is an embarrassment to the
senate to the country to the founders
and all that they profess to hold dear
and if this is america first then
america is [ __ ]
[Applause]
well there you have it uh jessica and
jon stewart i i couldn't stop i i didn't
want to play the whole thing but i
couldn't help myself um he's
uh a call to the nation
and it is it is up to us it is up to us
we can help and we've talked about it
before time and time again during the
hearings and today you have to engage in
your democracy that's why this is so
important john pointed out that god they
live to be 400 years old they're they're
they never leave we can make them leave
we always complain about term limits all
we need term limits they do have term
limits
they have term limits every six years we
can decide you're fired [ __ ] you do not
get to be a senator anymore because
you're not doing the job and that is up
to us it's up to us we the people to
engage in the ballot engage in our
democracy and do the thing that
democracies do
cast away the the garbage cast away the
garbage and put people there that are
gonna set policies not just for us but
for these veterans who served our
country
like john said they're not just heroes
these are real human beings where the
[ __ ] is the empathy where
is it
where is it anymore in this country
especially on the right
how have they gone so far away from what
the teachings of the bible that you were
talking about before of just plain
simple decent empathy
how how far have we come it is
ridiculous jessica they are gone the
republican party is gone they worship
the golden cow of greed this is who that
party is they have shown us again and
again
speaking about veterans it is so
sickening it is so sickening to see how
these people treat veterans
and and and then they go out and wave a
flag and like he said you know they they
brag about their gift their gift basket
with with hand sanitizer in it
sickening sickening but it goes back to
when i think when i have thought when
i've i as i have lived this experience
over the past five six years seeing how
these performative politicians trump and
his sycophants his his party this is
trump's party this is not an american
political party this is a dictator's
fascist anti-american party to see how
they wave the american flag the banner
of freedom
and then they live the opposite of it
and i have thought about all of the
people who have died for this country in
the
real name of freedom in the real service
of freedom and when i have gotten tired
and exhausted and
ticked off and like i am just pissed at
what i am seeing these people do day in
and day out i always come back to one
thing
and that is that we are the living
we are the living in this moment in
history
let us use our lives to honor those
sacrifices those real sacrifices that
real courage that real patriotism
it is up to us
so yes
everything is on the line 2022 could not
be more important we have the tools now
and we have a few months
a few months to pick up those tools to
do everything if you think you're doing
enough do more i've said this before
i'll say it again one one idea that i
like is the pay it forward idea keep a
list
put 10 numbers on it
get 10 people in your locality who you
know lean democrat or who you know
understand the threat in some way
whether it's because they're veterans or
a woman or you know a marginalized group
whatever it is and you and you know that
they they are going to be affected and
then they're not registered find 10
people who aren't registered to vote
because that's what we're talking about
in this election we are talking about
turnout
motivating the base and voter turnout
okay we talked a lot in this
conversation about you know waking up
the people who are brainwashed by these
performance politicians but we don't
even have to do that that would be great
that's like you know icing on the cake
if we just turn out the base
the biden coalition that got him in in
the first place
we have the numbers we have the numbers
we just have to turn them out we have to
lay down the stakes we have to let them
know the gas prices are temporary and
it's a global problem and it's not
biden's fault and please have the
foresight to look beyond this temporary
you know economic problem that a lot of
us are dealing with we literally have
the opportunities we are the living we
are the ones making history now
it is in your hand and in my hand to
determine whether america becomes a
fascist
state in 2022 or not
jessica what a note to end on thank you
for joining me today
it was so much fun
i i love having you on i love talking to
you uh you were kind of our guest
co-host today you know whether you knew
it or not so i appreciate please come
back soon and join us when gabe can join
us um maybe maybe we should uh
what's well you know he is he is he is
uh out in about the the
uh the last few days so he had that he
had to take a little time for himself
but he's in the place where the wi-fi
isn't exactly where he can stream he's
working in the background by the way
wasn't wasn't his precious premarital
self supposed to join us here on the
tony michael well i tried to get jordy
to join us but i think he's um he was
having a bit of trouble with some things
so i wasn't able to get him here
hopefully i'll i'll get him one of these
days i always try to get jordy on the
show you know i have to i i a lot of
people team jordy kind of came after me
a bit jessica i i joked with jordy the
last hearing we had i muted his muted
his might because he was uh he appeared
to be a little late um i made him appear
to be late and they they kind of came
after me so i owe jordy
an apology and i want to do it on the
air and i've tried a couple times to get
him here but he's been so busy trying to
save our democracy over at the minus
touch network
just
and jessica he's getting married soon
he's i know i know i know he's people i
don't know
a little bit of you know time to work on
the way i guess so what we're we're
trying he's trying to save democracy
he's trying to to to put a ring on that
finger so
a good example nothing nothing is more
important in this moment than saving
democracy not
married and he worked so hard at those
videos on the midas touch network as you
have appeared on the minus touch network
and i want you to come back because we
broadcast every single weekday noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and we simulcast
from the midas touch facebook page
and it's so important for you guys to
engage in your democracy not just listen
to this show but go out and use the
things you hear
here to to to push your community in a
way that is pro-democracy
so until tomorrow same time same place
jessica thanks for joining us
audience
surfs up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking